like is gonna start off this hour in
Michigan hey Mike how are you I'm great
good afternoon guys I hope you're
staying safe we are sir how about Jannah
so I've been following the baby steps
I'll be in a kind of did a little bit of
a hybrid version so hear me out if you
could I started my $1,000 emergency fund
the bank talked me into doing an extra
hundred per month so I'm at about 1500
now paid off you know the higher
interest credit cards and I just paid
off my last one last week actually
that's why I bought some debt free my
question is I have a thirteen thousand
dollars left on my mortgage I had a
15-year mortgage at six percent and I've
always kind of paint a little bit extra
but I know the next step in the baby
steps is saving at six months virtue fun
yeah would it be smart to aggressively
pay off the house and still continued
slowly to the emergency phone or those
do the emergency fund and worry about
the house later nope you get your
emergency fund in place dude you're
living square in the middle of a freakin
emergency have you noticed your Michigan
have you're walking metaphor for the
answer and I know you did you're right
there you're so close yeah the problem
is this thirteen thousand it's not 130
pounds yeah you can see it me and I
promise you can reach over and swagger
but never gonna happen
what is your household income okay so
what what is an emergency fund in five
to ten grand that's what the house thing
what if I get rid of that I'm down well
you're gonna get rid of that but okay so
yeah let's call it ten grand how long
does it take to put 10 grand aside if
you have no payments but the house which
is where you are right now you're about
to achieve that how long you can put ten
grand to set how is gonna take eight
months yep that sounds right to me and
if you can do that in six to eight
months and then six to eight months
later the house is paid off yeah
so really we're having a one-year
discussion right here
ain't that big of a center yeah for sure
yeah so so quite greatly appreciate it
well hey in this a value conversation
too I want folks to after you've paid
these credit card folks pay yourself
like you're worth putting money in the
bank for stead of dumping stuff off I
think that's a value judgment we often
pull ourselves out of this baby steps
conversation you're worth saving for and
I don't know man something's gonna
happen
God Almighty be great to have an
emergency fund I spent too many years in
crisis my bell bell curve is shifted and
messed over I just like well there may
be a car wreck and there be a I maybe I
need to go more counseling Dave but yeah
I know how hard that it's time can you
imagine the hate mail line we would have
gotten if six months ago I would have
said something like a disease is coming
and I'm gonna shut the whole nation down
for a month for two months Arjun Singh
fun instead I said you know grandma said
say for a rainy day because sometimes it
rains as a matter of fact about all that
you can predict is change so you need to
be ready and one lady called it the G
okay fun the god only knows fun you know
and god only knows god only you know the
co food was gonna shut the whole place
down for a period of time and people
were gonna lose their jobs and who knew
you were gonna feel different if you had
$20,000 in the bank instead of $20,000
in credit card debt
who knew common sense knew that's whom
everyone should know everyone should
know but and the you know if you didn't
then this is your call this is your
wake-up call answer the phone never
again say never again never never again
when I went broke I said never again
and I never again I've been without an
emergency fund I never again have used
that I never I was through I learned my
lesson so the bad things happen to you
and then you learn your lesson or you
get to repeat the test so you've worked
with millions of people what's them what
is so crisis comes and there's two
responses one is to try to insulate
yourself and never let that thing happen
again and I'm going to do that by
running as fast as I can from it and
then there's something about turning the
table
saying I will absorb the next one of
these it comes you've you've helped
millions of people what's that what's
what's the what is the characteristic
what's the character trait that someone
turns around and says I'm not gonna run
I'm gonna have somebody in my family die
I'm gonna have a car that breaks down
I'm gonna be ready when it happens not
I'm gonna run from those from being
scared and I'm gonna run from no one's
ever gonna die in my life so you're
saying it's the same response as a
different motivation in both cases we're
building an emergency fund but some
people are doing it because they're
running and some people are doing it
because they want to be ready well so
let's say a pandemic comes there's gonna
be a crew of people they're gonna
there's gonna be a crop of Industry that
shows up it says never get sick from a
virus again and they're gonna you know
chase down vitamins and workout programs
and this and that they're not gonna save
money they're not going to get connected
to their families they're not gonna do
the thing that is going to be pandemic
proof or death in the family proof or
insurance didn't cover flood whatever
the thing is proof does that make sense
yeah okay yeah cuz you know what you can
you can prescribe the wrong medicine for
the illness yeah it's this idea of we're
gonna chase the black swans and you
missed the whole point that a Black Swan
comes and you don't know what's coming
and so you can build a resilient life or
is Talab says an anti fragile life that
says come what may I'm gonna have an
emergency phone I'm gonna have a
community of people around me I'm gonna
have a church that I rely on or I'm just
gonna keep chasing down the next the
next rabbit trail oh that got me last
time so that will never get me again
yeah it's not it's not that won't ever
get me again and that's why we say you
know three to six months of expenses and
somebody says well you know I'm in the
military and my wife works at the post
office we're not gonna lose their jobs
well losing your job is only one
possible emergency right your
transmission going out and your your
aunt passing away across on the other
side of the nation and they need you to
pay for the funeral is another type of
emergency unaccounted to get bad enough
that that they're gonna shift then you
know let's brown the great motivator
says people change their lives when they
say I've had it I've had it and so it it
usually the
the healthy response usually comes from
a righteous anger okay not at not at
yourself and and not at other people but
at the concept okay I've had it I will
never be here again I've had it right
and you know like my mother you know a
bunch of redneck hillbilly kids we'd be
running there now that I was running out
the house and she would finally reach a
boiling point she would say that's it
the worm has turned
we even know what that meant found out
later was Shakespeare who knew no mom
knew Shakespeare well we knew was the
beatings were about to begin
you know that's I've had it and when you
go that's it then then you're ready to
change your life never again am I gonna
be in a relation am I gonna be caught
off glad about whatever about whatever
I'm not gonna do that thing that way
ever again